on est largement au temps limite vaut
presque en voyant ces scènes n'ont
qu'une jolie celle du baseball
je viens de remarquer que jeudi la
première fois embrassez moi et après la
deuxième fois le nom j'avais jamais
remarqué ça c'est une judiciaire vous
vous savez évidemment que cette cette
scène et 7 cette réplique c'est quelque
chose qui a couru à travers les écrits
dans les airs c'est tout ça est quand
même temps ça peut-être aussi couru chez
les amoureux chez les coûts non c'est
d'être oui vous allez penser quelque peu
après le ballon je n'ai pas pensé il ya
près de 10 non non mais je dois dire que
chaque fois que je revois la scène il ya
une émotion dans cette scène c'est
peut-être parce que j'avais très peur de
ne pas bien
la faire il faut dire que gamètes est
très taquin et il me taquinait toujours
enfin on se connaissait pas tellement
bon sens très bien et à ce moment-là et
et alors il disait son ami l'ombre je
suis sûr que cette mommens et pas
embrassés ça m'énervait jamais il disait
toujours pas la belle à elle c'était
près mais elle savait bien embrasser
alors j'étais un peu impressionné par ça
et j'ai voulu montrer que quand même
vous étiez te piquer me prend pour une
gamine messieurs les montres voilà c'est
ça j'avais 18 ans voilà j'avais 18 ans
peut-être voir d'ailleurs